LEIGH GALLAGHER: Thank
you for having us.
This is really exciting.
Thanks to Jacob and to Google.
It's great to be here.
I run our "best companies to
work for" list, among many
other things, at Fortune.
And you guys are always a
stalwart, if not the winner.
So it's great to be here and
see it all in action.
So when people ask me-- when I
tell people I'm writing this
book, or when I was writing the
book, and I would say, oh,
I'm writing a book about the
end of the suburbs--
I have a section in the book,
actually, where I talk a lot
about this, because everybody
has some kind of emotional
connection to this topic
and this argument.
The argument's very clear when
I tell them what the book is
called, "The End of
the Suburbs."
And so everyone's--
I got a lot of high fives,
good for you.
That's awesome.
That's great.
I got a lot of, I live
in the suburbs.
I hate it there.
I got a lot of, I live
in the suburbs but
I have to be there.
Without kind of asking for
this reaction, I got a
tremendous amount of
people's pent up
issues about the suburbs.
And I'm not anti-suburb.
I wrote this book for a number
of reasons, not because I
think that the suburbs are
bad and evil, and I'm a
condo-dwelling,
espresso-drinking urbanist.
JESSI HEMPEL: But you are.
LEIGH GALLAGHER: It's not
technically a condo.
But I was shocked at the
response I got while I was
reporting this book.
And towards the end--
I say this in the book--
towards the end of the
process, I would be out at
cocktail parties or wherever
and small talk-- this project
would come up.
And in addition to people's
opinions about it, people had
lots of questions about it.
And people wanted to
engage about it.
talk about it.
And as I approached my deadline,
I stopped bringing
it up on purpose, because I knew
that if I brought it up,
it would mean I would be in
conversation for another 45
minutes when I really had to get
home and finish the book.
So it struck a chord.
It struck kind of
a lightning rod.
But not a negative one.
I was telling Jessi in the car
over, I've gotten a lot less
hate mail than I thought
I would.
JESSI HEMPEL: So we're
going to get to
the hate mail question.
Let's back up.
I mean, I don't want to presume
that we understand the
thesis from the title
of your book.
LEIGH GALLAGHER: Sure, yes.
JESSI HEMPEL: What
are you trying to
say about the suburbs?
LEIGH GALLAGHER: Well, the
thesis of the book is a little
bit more nuanced
than the title.
What happened was I started
observing--
there was the very sort of
whiffs of census data had come
out that sort of had the
framework of a very big story
that I thought wasn't
being told.
And the gist of the thesis is
basically that we are, as an
American people, really tired of
the suburban lifestyle for
a number of reasons.
And the suburban lifestyle is
actually how most people in
this country live.
That's starting to change, but
in terms of percentage, number
of homes, number of people,
we are a suburban country.
So I thought, if that's true
that our sort of love affair
with the American suburbs
is peaking, that is a
very, very big deal.
And that's worth exploring.
So then I set out
in exploring it.
So the reasons we're tiring
from it are numerous.
And they're complicated.
And it's not because of
the financial crisis.
It's because of--
or the housing crisis.
It's because of a number of
other longer-term forces.
But the thesis is that people
are tiring what has been held
up as this pillar of the
iconic American dream.
The thesis is not that
everyone's going to live in a
skyscraper in New York City.
That's impractical.
That's not the way most people
in this country want to live.
So the thesis is more one of
kind of urbanism everywhere.
People want to live in a place
where they can walk to get a
cup of coffee.
That's basically the thesis.
JESSI HEMPEL: So we understand
that you're addressing a bunch
of structural issues.
To really understand the shift,
let's go back to the
idea of what a suburb
was supposed to be
in the first place.
As a child of the '70s and '80s,
I thought until I was an
adult that suburbs were the de
facto way that people lived.
But they're actually fairly
recent, right?
LEIGH GALLAGHER: Yeah,
they really--
our modern suburbs are the
product of a series of
policies and a sort of
particular perfect storm of
where we were as a country
right after World War II.
So I spend a lot of time in
the book talking about the
history of how the suburbs
came to be.
And it's really fascinating.
And it just very much mirrors
where we were as a country.
So there were suburbs--
I actually go back to
Mesopotamia in the beginning
of the book, but don't
let that sway you.
We had suburbs--
our first real suburbs were
these sort pre-war, in the
1800s, villages that sprouted up
kind of organically around
train stations.
Our housing pattern is always
arranged around our
transportation, because you have
to be able to get around.
So when the only way to get
around was by rail or by
street car, and then on your
own two feet, towns were
designed a lot differently.
They were--
here was the rail station.
And the towns kind of came up
organically around traditional
urban planning design, which was
a grid pattern, which had
been that from the days going
back into antiquity.
And the densest area was right
around the station.
And that's where the villages
shops set up shop--
the shops set up, because that
was the easiest place for
people to get off the train
and do their errands
and then walk home.
And so as a result, these towns
had a very organic feel.
And it's a very pleasant feel.
These are towns that we see now
in a lot of the suburbs
around New York City
that are older--
have that kind of design.
They're all over the country.
But it really has more to do
with age than anything else,
because they were built
around people and
people's day-to-day needs.
And then--
JESSI HEMPEL: Well, so right
there, you said they do their
errands and then
they walk home.
It seems like a lot changed
when walking
was replaced by driving.
LEIGH GALLAGHER: Yeah.
That's what kind of blew up the
entire model and led to
something else.
And that happened after-- well,
a number of things.
The car was invented in
the early 1900's.
But it didn't really take off,
and didn't really catch hold
with the middle class,
until right after--
well, I don't know--
the '30s, the '40s.
But the whole explosion happened
after World War II,
when we had all these returning
GIs coming back from
the war, millions of them.
We had a housing shortage, which
is hard to even imagine
now, because we have the exact
opposite problem now.
But after World War II, we had
16 million GIs coming home and
nowhere to put them.
People were living with their
parents, living in dining
rooms-- people were living
all over the place.
So we had this housing
problem.
And at the same time, the
car had just taken off.
There were federal policies
that had put in place the
Federal Highway Act, which lay
the groundwork for 41,000
miles of paved roads for us to
get to and from these towns.
We were sort of--
there was this wonder of mass
production in the home
building industry
and everywhere.
So the housing companies had
just been able to perfect the
technique of mass producing
single-family homes.
And the FHA had been created
to fund long-term mortgages
and make home ownership a
reality for everybody.
So all these things kind of
combusted together and they
just led to this explosion
in a different kind of
development, which was the
cutting and pasting of these
much more modern subdivisions
and suburban communities all
across the country.
And they have a very
different design.
The streets are wider.
They're loopy.
It's like cul-de-sacs that
feed into other connector
roads that feed into
arterial roads.
There's a very specific
blueprint
for the modern suburbs.
And that's what worked.
They thought this was the future
and then everyone just
seized on it.
And that's why a lot of the
towns that are a byproduct of
that era tend to look similar.
JESSI HEMPEL: So golden age for
the suburb, like if you
could go back in time to a
specific year and it was the
thing, what year would it be?
LEIGH GALLAGHER: People
are obsessed with--
oh, gosh.
That's a really good question.
I would say--
I don't know, 1884.
The late 1800s.
JESSI HEMPEL: OK, that's
the old suburbs.
I'm talking like Don
Draper time.
LEIGH GALLAGHER: 19--
I have to look.
I have a couple stats
in the book that--
there was a house that was built
in like three hours.
I mean, this was really--
the machine was cranking
on all cylinders.
And it was--
JESSI HEMPEL: I don't think any
of us would want to live
in that house.
LEIGH GALLAGHER: No.
Although, we did it again
during the housing boom.
Those houses were built
pretty quickly too.
But it was probably
the mid-1950s.
Levittown, the iconic suburb on
Long Island, was built-- it
opened in 1946 or '47.
And that was sort of the
first of these modern
subdivision-style, mass-produced
suburbs.
That was the beginning of the
modern suburban area.
And then from then on, I mean,
that's still what we have.
And it worked very, very well.
I mean, look at all of us here
who grew up in the suburbs.
This was the American way
of life-- the '50s,
the '60s, the '70s--
I would say it started to change
in the '80s, when we
just sort of jumped the shark
a little bit in terms of the
development of the suburbs.
And we saw the beginning of real
suburban sprawl, where
towns sort of ceased having a
center and it was all sort of
about the strip mall and the
office complex and the
commercial center.
And then the houses were
somewhere different and very,
very far away from
all that stuff.
JESSI HEMPEL: One thing you
talk about in your book is
social isolation.
And it strikes me that that
hasn't actually changed.
So I'm curious, what has changed
around that over time?
I mean, it had to be true that
the experience of living in
the suburbs in the '60s was
fairly isolating, no?
LEIGH GALLAGHER: You
know, yes and no.
It's funny, I mean, I think in
the '60s the towns were--
the scale was still
a little smaller.
There were still centers to
a lot of these towns.
And it was this sort of happy
"Wonder Years" era where
everyone had lots and
lots of children.
And so there were more people
in the communities.
And they did have a bit
of a livelier feel.
But even back then--
I traced--
I spent a lot of time, this was
really fun just looking--
when you're a writer, you
just look for any
rabbit hole to go down.
And you're kind of
procrastinating.
So I spent a lot of time going
and looking at old YouTube
videos of "The Wonder Years"
or all the pop culture
references to the suburbs in our
culture, because they're
everywhere.
And one of the interesting
things I found was that it's
kind of common now to take
potshots at suburbia.
If you look at "Weeds" or
"American Beauty" or
"Desperate Housewives" or
"Suburgatory," all these kind
of things that poke fun at--
whether it's the cookie cutter
nature or the dark underbelly,
that it looks so
picture perfect
but people have issues.
That was also happening
in the '50s.
I mean, there was this book
called "The Crack in the
Picture Window." It was actually
the basis for the
movie "Revolutionary
Road" much later.
But it was sort of a very
dark look at suburbia.
And then you had, even,
"Blue Velvet"--
very, very dark look at it.
And then even this famous song--
the most famous song
about the suburbs, probably--
the song "Little Boxes," which
was used as the theme song for
"Weeds" in an amazing way.
And with all these
amazing covers.
JESSI HEMPEL: Everybody
familiar with it?
LEIGH GALLAGHER: I wish
we had audio here.
JESSI HEMPEL: Anybody want
to sing it for us?
No volunteers.
LEIGH GALLAGHER: It's great.
It's a great song.
The original song is great.
But it was in 19--
was it '62--
very early on that this song
came out that was just
completely pointing out how
terrible the suburbs were.
And how everyone looks all the
same and everyone went to the
same colleges.
And this is all--
it just was really,
really dark.
And so very early on, people
were pointing out that this
might not be the best
way for our housing
landscape to be arranged.
JESSI HEMPEL: And of course,
since then suburbs have become
exurbs and they've sprawled
further out.
And gas prices have gone up.
So talk to us a little bit about
the relationship between
the suburb and the car.
LEIGH GALLAGHER: Sure.
I have a whole chapter in the
book about the suburb and the
car, because that's where
the whole experiment
kind of went wrong.
I mean, I don't want to be
such a suburb hater.
But that's really-- what a lot
of people's problems with the
suburbs, and why people are
leaving, relates to problems
they have with the suburbs.
And almost all of those problems
relate to the suburbs
being designed around the car.
So there wouldn't be one
without the other.
This was this magical idea
that we were all going to
drive to these communities and
use the car to get around and
everything.
But what that means is that
people don't really walk in a
lot of suburbs.
I talked to a doctor who has
spent a lot of time focusing
on-- he's a former director of
the CDC who's now really,
really focused on this issue
of our built environment.
That's the phrase people use to
talk about your everyday--
the way our landscape
is built--
and its impact on
public health.
So he estimates that
New Yorkers--
I put this in the book.
I don't want to come off like
a snobby New Yorker, but--
JESSI HEMPEL: She's not
a snobby New Yorker.
LEIGH GALLAGHER: But New Yorkers
weigh on average six
or seven pounds less than the
average suburban American
precisely because we have
to walk everywhere.
And New York, I think, is
a very extreme example.
Where we walk here--
walking even one city block in
New York City is more than
most people in this country
walk in a given day.
And that's not an
exaggeration.
I mean, it's like, if you've
ever had friends come out of
town who live in LA or anywhere
else and they--
this is for women-- but they
pack their high heels and then
you go out.
And you lose them after like a
half a block, because they're
like, what are we doing?
I mean, it's just--
People don't walk in the
rest of the country.
And that's largely because of
the way our residential
environment is designed.
And so there's a difference
between living in a
community--
I read a lot about the
suburb I grew up in,
which is an old suburb.
It has a really adorable
downtown.
There's a trolley.
There's a courthouse.
There's a Main Street.
It's very-- it's kind
of the ideal.
It's what a lot of people want
to move to, and what a lot of
communities now want to be.
But when you live near a
community like that, you don't
have to live where you
can walk to it.
It's one thing--
you drive a mile to
that community.
And then you get out and you
have a pleasing place to walk.
But a lot of people live
10 or 15 miles from
any place like that.
And 10 or 15 miles from
a place to even
buy a gallon of milk.
So that's just--
you're in your car
all the time.
Atlanta's like this.
Thanks to the housing boom of
the 2000s, every state has--
every urban center has a place
like this, because the
development pushed so
out into the fringe.
And so a lot of people are
living where they are
commuting up to 70 miles one
way, where they're--
JESSI HEMPEL: And you mentioned
in the book-- and I
thought this was funny--
that everybody always
underestimates their commute.
Like, if I asked you--
I don't know, what's your
commute to work?
Yeah, yours.
10 minutes.
OK, you probably have an
exact count on that.
The close nature.
Some suburban in the audience,
raise your hand.
Let's get one.
OK, how do you get to work?
AUDIENCE: I bike, I take
the train, and I walk.
JESSI HEMPEL: How long do
you think it takes you?
AUDIENCE: An hour and
twenty minutes.
JESSI HEMPEL: An hour and 20
minutes every day, both ways.
Each way.
And so what Leigh--what you also
discovered in your book
is that when you're estimating
that time-- and I'm assuming
that at Google, giving your
prowess in technology it's an
exact estimate.
But the rest of the world is
sometimes a little bit off and
always underestimates that.
It always takes more time.
LEIGH GALLAGHER:
Yeah, they do.
I mean, according to the census,
the average commute
right now, I think, is
26 minutes one way.
That's a big average, so you're
factoring in lots of things.
But it's really hard to get the
exact data, because people
do under report it.
And that's because they don't
want to think that they've
made this decision to
live so far away.
But wait, I had the
perfect life.
I have the house with my
yard and everything.
So there's a lot of
data on commuting.
And it's really fascinating.
I mean, the things it does to
people-- it's not good for,
one thing, just time.
And I think a lot of people
move to the suburbs-- the
biggest reason by far is to
prioritize schools and family
life for children.
JESSI HEMPEL: So you wrote
about a family like that.
A family who lived in Cambridge,
Massachusetts and
was having more children
and decided this is it.
And they moved to a town close
to my heart, Westborough,
Massachusetts, only because
I grew up in the
town next to it.
And they didn't last
very long.
So tell us the story
of that family.
LEIGH GALLAGHER: Sure.
This is the woman--
I have a chapter in the
book that's about the
suburbs and the car.
And the quote came from this
woman-- the quote for the
title of the chapter.
It's called, "My Car Knows the
Way to Gymnastics." And what
she meant by that was--
they'd moved--
I forget where they moved
from, but they'd--
actually, her husband works
at Google, I think.
But anyway--
we don't need to go into that.
But they had moved with
their three children.
They had their fourth child
shortly after they moved into
this colonial house
in Westborough.
And the woman really wanted
to try the American dream.
She said, I've never
done this.
I really want to do it.
I want the car.
I want the minivan.
I want the house.
I want the whole deal.
And she was dissatisfied for
a number of reasons.
But one of the biggest reasons
was because she really
underestimated the amount of
time she was going to spend in
her car every day, which ended
up being close to 40 or 50
miles a day because she
had four children.
And just to shuttle them around
to all the activities
they need to be in--
I mean, if there's parents
in the room, I'm sure you
understand this.
It's soccer practice, piano
lessons, Hebrew lessons--
everything.
And so she was in her car from
three to six every day,
traveling these vast distances
to take her kids to all their
engagements.
And she just really thought that
she was going to move to
a suburb and there was going
to be serendipitous play
happening in the streets-- that
kids would play in the
street or in the backyard
with the swing set.
That was the whole point.
And they would play until it was
time for dinner and then
they would come in.
And that just didn't happen.
She said to me, there's a
playset in every backyard, but
you don't have access
to that playset
unless you have a playdate.
So I think part of that is the
whole playdate-centric culture
is also alive and
well in cities.
I think that's also a result
of how having two parents
working now-- we didn't
have that back in
the '60s, '70s, '80s.
I think it's part of our--
I think the culture around
parenting has
changed a little bit.
There's far more activities
for everyone to do.
I don't know that that's
just a suburban thing.
But that is one reason why
children growing up in the
suburbs today have a very
different childhood than I had
when I was growing up in the
suburbs in the '70s, when we
did play outside until 6 o'clock
and it was time for
dinner and when there
were tons of
children running around.
And so she was really
disaffected with that aspect,
and then with the aspect
that nobody walked or--
they actually lived close to
their school and she tried to
organize an effort to get the
parents to walk a group of
kids to school every day.
And nobody would do it.
They didn't want do it.
JESSI HEMPEL: So tell
me what happened.
So here's a family
with four kids.
I mean, they don't fit into
a two-bedroom apartment.
What did they decide to do?
LEIGH GALLAGHER: They ended
up moving to Cambridge.
They pulled the kids
out of school and
they found a row house.
It wasn't cheap.
They had to spend more money
than-- they incurred a serious
financial burden to be
able to do this.
And she was well aware that not
everyone is able to just
change their mind like that,
because the suburbs are more
economical given the schools
and everything.
But they-- they are living
a much happier
life, all of them.
All six of them.
Their kids love it.
They walk to museums.
They go to a park across the
street when they want to play.
They have a postage
stamp backyard.
They have a row house, less
space, but they have the kind
of life that they're
really enjoying.
So that might not be
for everybody.
But I found a whole lot of
people who did something like
that, who actually move to
the suburbs and then
moved back to cities.
I mean, it's one thing to have--
here in New York, we
have a lot of families who
actually opt to stay in the
city and never go out
to the suburbs.
But I found a lot of people who
are moving back, and many
times even sending their kids
to public school in cities.
JESSI HEMPEL: So how are cities
changing to become more
friendly places to live?
LEIGH GALLAGHER: Well,
it's funny.
I mean, there's a kind
of reversal going on.
The cities are actually
becoming
a little more suburban.
I mean, they're just much nicer
places to live than they
were in the '70s and '80s when
everyone rushed out and went
to the suburbs.
So the narrative
around cities--
I'm sure everyone here has read
stories or books about
this in the past couple years.
But cities are--
all over the country,
except for Detroit--
Detroit is a real outlier.
And some of the other
rust belt cities.
But cities are really
wildly resurgent
for a number of reasons.
Crime has gone down.
Public and private investment
has gone way up.
They're just vastly
different places.
Industry has moved out.
I mean, one of the reasons why
everyone left the cities was
because we had a lot of noxious
factories, dating--
I mean, that goes way back
to when we were more of a
manufacturing-based economy.
And you have--
cities now are--
JESSI HEMPEL: Now those
noxious factories are
beautiful lofts.
LEIGH GALLAGHER:
Yes, they are.
Exactly.
And expensive lofts.
I mean, look at--
the meat packing district is--
you wouldn't have gone there
even in the '80s and '90s.
And now it's like a casting call
for "The Bachelorette." I
mean, it's like--
everyone goes there.
Everyone goes out.
Cities are like amusement
parks now.
And so that's been
a huge shift.
Its driven the prices up,
especially in New York, but--
JESSI HEMPEL: So let's talk
a little bit about the
economics of cities.
I mean, is what you're talking
about a phenomenon that really
only affects the upper
class and the very
upper middle class.
Can the middle class afford
to live in cities?
LEIGH GALLAGHER: That's
a good question.
It depends on the city.
Not New York City or not
Manhattan for sure.
And the suburbs were originally
a big solution for
our middle class.
And that's why they
were built.
And our middle class
is shrinking.
And so that's, I think, one
reason we're seeing actually
really high levels of poverty
in the suburbs now.
So it is a bit of an economic--
it's more expensive
to live in a city than a suburb,
especially if you have
to pay for private schools.
But one of the big movements
that's happening, and one of
the things I spend a lot of time
on in the book is this
movement to sort of urbanize
the suburbs.
People really want to go back
to this model where there is
some sort of cute, lively
town center.
And a pleasing place to go
and bump into people.
And a lot of people want that.
Whether it's in the suburbs
or the city,
that's all they want.
And so a lot of home builders
and developers and planners
are kind of falling all over
themselves right now to sort
of build these sort of
utopian urban burbs.
And they don't really
exist now.
I mean, they exist in a few
different places, but there's
not nearly enough of them to
suit the demand that's coming.
So the ideal does not have
to be moving into a city.
People just want--
JESSI HEMPEL: Is this like
the river towns, like
hipsturbias--
Terry Town and Hastings
on Hudson?
LEIGH GALLAGHER: Yeah,
that's close to it.
LEIGH GALLAGHER: I mean, the New
York Times did this story
with the headline "Hipsturbia"
back several months ago.
And it was all about how
hipsters were-- the Brooklyn
class was now moving up to the
river towns, which offer this
kind of really funky town where
there's a Main Street
and a yoga studio and a coffee
shop and all that stuff.
And they do, because those towns
were built on the sort
of old urban bones.
Not just the river towns,
but other New
York suburbs as well.
But it's funny.
I mean, I talked to a friend of
mine who lives in Hastings.
And I said, oh, did you see?
You live in Hipsturbia.
And he sort of rolled
his eyes.
He said, you know, this
isn't hipsters.
He said this is like upstate
with corporate lawyers.
Because it's really
expensive there.
And he said you're still
in your car a lot.
I mean, no matter what you're
still in your car a lot when
you live in the suburbs.
But that is--
I think people are really
starting to draw this
distinction between
the "Weeds"-style,
cul-de-sac-heavy, big,
cut-and-pasted suburb and the
one with more character.
And usually, those are
a little bit older.
And we're starting to
see a reversal in
valuations, where those--
in some places, neighborhoods
that are older are retaining
their housing values more so
than newer neighborhoods,
which-- in the past, that
was always reversed.
People always want new.
And you're starting to see
that revers a little bit.
It's one of a number of
reversals in economic
valuations that play into
this whole thesis.
JESSI HEMPEL: And so you talked
in the book about a man
who launched an interesting
experiment that essentially
got squashed when the housing
bust happened.
But it was an experiment to
give mortgages based on a
broader picture than basic
pen-and-paper financial
ability to pay.
Can you talk a little
bit about what
that experiment was?
LEIGH GALLAGHER: Sure.
This is this outfit out of
Chicago called the Center for
Neighborhood Technologies.
And there's a guy there named
Scott Bernstein who is just a
real kind of genius
in this field.
And he had spent a lot of time--
his whole expertise,
and this organization's
expertise, is quantifying how
much transportation costs eat
up disposable income.
And so people think about
the cost it takes to
fill up your gas tank.
But it's not just that.
I mean, anybody who owns
a car knows this.
It's the cost of maintenance.
It's the cost of--
I mean, everything that goes
into owning a car-- parking
and all that stuff.
And so he did a lot of
calculations across the
country and found that in many
markets, usually the market's
that are the farthest from the
sort of urban center, the sort
of "drive to qualify" zone, as
it was called during the
housing boom, because the people
who could least afford
it were going the furthest to
find the house they wanted.
And actually, this woman in
Boston said that too.
They went so far way because if
you're going to spend, you
want it to be the best
house you can buy.
And that's part of this house
American dream psyche mania
that we have going.
But anyway, he found that in
many communities, people were
spending as much or more of
their disposable income, or
their monthly income, on their
transportation costs as their
housing costs.
And that's largely because when
you're doing a 70 mile
commute, or two per household,
that's a lot of money.
And people don't think about
that when they think about
their housing costs.
They really don't.
You just think of the
house itself.
But that's eating up just tons
and tons and tons of
people's-- it's taking a huge
hit on people's wallets.
So anyway, he basically devised
this idea for a
location-efficient mortgage, he
called it, where the cost
of transportation was
built and baked into
your monthly nut.
And to the kind of mortgage
you were going
to be able to get.
And you would be able to qualify
for a bigger mortgage
if you lived in a more
responsible place.
So just actually baking in where
the house was located
into the actual total cost of
your house that the bank was
willing to lend for.
And kind of acknowledging that
that was a huge part of the
expense of the house was going
to be where it's built.
And so they did really well.
They did studies on
these mortgages.
And in a study of 300 of them
or something, there was one
that failed.
And it didn't even
ever default.
They fixed it before
it came to default.
So these have been
proven to work.
And they're an idea that a lot
of people think makes a whole
lot of sense.
But the housing bust and our
economic crisis came around.
And they never-- they haven't
really gotten traction.
It's very hard to get the banks
to move on something
that doesn't act in
their interests.
JESSI HEMPEL: That
is indeed true.
Indeed true.
So you also address this startup
doing something called
a walkability score.
LEIGH GALLAGHER: Yeah.
So this is a startup that people
here might have heard
of called Walk Score.
And what Walk Score does is it
uses all sorts of algorithms
to be able to give you a score
from 1 to 100 on how walkable
your neighborhood is.
And you just plug in
any address and it
will give you a score.
So I live on West 10th
street in Manhattan.
And my walk score is 100,
which means that I can
basically walk anywhere
I need to go.
Where I grew up in Media,
Pennsylvania--
I forget what the score is.
I think it's in the 20s.
But that's considered
car dependent.
So you can do this anywhere.
So it's really fun to
play around with.
And this company is really
riding a wave of buzz in terms
of what people are demanding
from their houses and their
neighborhoods.
So walkability is kind of this
big new buzz word in real
estate circles.
And real estate agents are
starting to use it.
It's being promoted
everywhere--
new communities.
The walkability of a
neighborhood is really seen as
a huge thing that people
are looking for.
So 15,000 real estate agencies
are now baking in the API to
their websites, because when
you're shopping for a house,
in addition to what it looks
like, how many bedrooms, is it
a colonial, whatever, people
are interested
in what it's near.
And I think that really reflects
a huge change in what
people are looking for from
the places they live.
So it's a huge thing.
And those communities are going
to be able to command
higher prices and do better.
We don't have enough of them.
So--
JESSI HEMPEL: So afterwards
she'll give us all some
tutoring based on where to
invest based on this, right?
LEIGH GALLAGHER: Somebody said I
could open a consultancy and
advise people where
to live, so--
JESSI HEMPEL: On that note,
let's open up to the audience.
Do we have any questions
in our audience?
All right, we've got somebody
at the mic.
AUDIENCE: Good afternoon.
Thank you for coming.
I know a little bit about--
not I know about real estate,
but I know a little bit about
real estate in the Central
Valley of California and
Bakersfield.
And they have, for instance,
this gigantic construction on
the grapevine called Fort Tejon
Ranch, which is utterly
enormous in the middle
of the highest point.
Just a terrible place
to have a complex.
But also, in Bakersfield itself,
a ton of new home
construction.
And it looks like a nice
suburban area.
What I find interesting about
these new homes is that
they're not actually
selling the home.
It's a giant town
home complex.
So you don't actually--
you don't own the home in the
same way that I own my home.
I have the right to do whatever
I want to the
exterior of my house.
And it seems like this is a way
to bring the cost of the
house down for people
in that area who
want to live in houses.
There are hardly any apartments
in Bakersfield.
But I wonder if this is a trend
that you've seen to make
housing more affordable,
but less--
but really, you don't own
the house in the same
way that you own--
again, in the same
way that I do.
So I wonder what this
trend means.
JESSI HEMPEL: So it's sort of
like a New York City co-op.
LEIGH GALLAGHER: It does.
It's townhouses?
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: They're
full-size homes.
They're full-size, multifamily
homes.
Bakersfield has very few
apartment buildings because
there's so much space
to sprawl out.
Not unlike Los Angeles.
Well, Los Angeles is much
more contained.
But it's just houses
after houses.
And they're building and
building and building.
And that paused for a while
a few years ago.
But they're back
in full force.
LEIGH GALLAGHER: Well,
if this is some sort
of innovative way--
I don't quite know the
structure here.
But people don't necessarily--
the home ownership rate
is following.
And renting and other types of
financial arrangements are
definitely gaining ground.
I don't know if this is a sort
of communal setup or if it's--
I don't know exactly what
the structure is.
But I thought you were going to
say they were sort of town
homes, which is interesting
because more urban kind of
style of development is coming
everywhere, even in places
like Bakersfield, which
is ground zero
for drive-to qualify.
Absolutely.
The people there do the longest
commutes in the country.
And I actually have an anecdote
in my book about a
woman who had to leave
her house at 4:00--
she got up at 3:50,
left at 4:00.
Only then would the commute be
only an hour and 15 minutes.
But then she'd get
there at 5:15.
And so she and her husband,
they were rare.
They actually commuted
together.
And they would go and park in
the McDonald's parking lot and
recline their seats and set
their cellphones and just
sleep for an hour.
And on the days when she was
alone, she would drive right
to her classroom--
she was a teacher--
and she would take a
nap under her desk.
And then once it was time to get
ready, she would get ready
in the ladies' room, and bring
her flat iron and everything.
But she would literally
sleep under her desk
for an hour or two.
She said she felt like
George Costanza from
the Seinfeld episode.
This is a New York audience.
You guys get that, right?
JESSI HEMPEL: All right,
let's jump to this
question over here.
AUDIENCE: I was just wondering
if in the course of your
research you reached any
conclusions about the size of
new house construction and the
impact it has on some of the
things you're describing.
Because I live in the suburbs.
One thing that I've noticed is
that a house that's the normal
size house like my house, like
2000 square feet, they just
don't build houses like
that anymore.
New construction is like 3,500
square feet, 3,800 square
feet, 4,200 square feet.
And I was just wondering if
you'd seen any impact of that.
LEIGH GALLAGHER: That's a
really good question.
That is changing.
The housing boom and bust really
kind of changed the
psyche on the whole excess
consumption and everything.
Statistically, the average size
of a new home has not--
it's come down a little bit.
Then it went up a little bit in
2011 because for a really
long period of time--
or during the peak of the
financial crisis, the only
people that were buying houses
were very wealthy who were
paying cash.
So it skewed the numbers
little bit.
But overall in the zeitgeist,
and the home builders, are
changing the way they
are building houses.
They don't ever use the word
"small." It's not a word they
like to talk about.
So they will say our homes
are now right size.
Or the floor plans are
a little different.
And they're making more
"efficient" use of space.
That's what everyone's
talking about.
But anecdotally--
JESSI HEMPEL: Efficiency
is such a good word.
LEIGH GALLAGHER: It is.
But that's--
people don't want houses where
they're not using the space
that they bought and paid for.
It costs a lot to
heat and cool.
And people are really starting
to recognize this. that.
So you're seeing all these kind
of interesting movements
come to be also, like life
edited, which has gotten a lot
of coverage here in New York.
Graham Hill, who founded
TreeHugger, has this new
movement about just reducing
the amount of
stuff that you have.
And his TED talk got like
two million views.
There is a movement in the
homebuilding industry for the
not-so-big house movement.
There's an architect,
Sarah Susanka-- or
she's a home designer.
And she advocates for building
differently, so that you're
using more of the
space every day.
And so we're definitely seeing
a lot more interest in that.
And the types of communities
people want, they tend to be
communities that have
smaller houses.
JESSI HEMPEL: So let's pop
over here for a question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm curious as to how--
I think there's sort of an
elephant in the room in the
story you've been telling,
because--
the things that you've been
talking about, people moving
to the suburbs to go to good
schools, people being in
cities having to buy
private schools.
And the whole white flight of
the '60s and '70s and the
urban decline thing is,
in a lot of ways,
a story about race.
And I wonder how that ties in
with the story of suburbia,
because it was an explicit
policy in this country that
the newly built suburbs were
going to be for white people.
And that was a really
big factor in why
everybody moved out there.
I'm wondering how that figures
into everything.
LEIGH GALLAGHER: Yeah,
great question.
It's true.
Back when the FHA--
I won't get too bogged
down in history.
But there was a process when
homes were approved for
different kinds of mortgages.
And homes that were
red lined--
it was explicit or
inexplicit--
blacks were denied benefits that
were flowing to whites
when it came to the kinds of
houses they could buy and the
neighborhoods they could live.
Totally a huge part of
our housing history.
As the suburbs grew and grew and
grew, they got so big that
they became this jumble and
began to reflect everything
about America.
So you now have suburbs in every
shape, flavor, size,
style, economic class, race,
ethnicity, and everything.
So they are much more reflective
now of America in
sum than they were when they
were born and created,
absolutely.
But the home ownership
rate in this
country is 64% on average.
For whites, it's 74%.
And for blacks, it's 44%.
So the policies behind home
ownership are still--
there's vast differences.
And so that's, I think, still
a huge issue in our housing
market in general.
I don't think it plays so much
a role into the migration
that's happening now.
I think it's a bit
more everyone.
The trends I write about really
impact everybody.
JESSI HEMPEL: Let's jump here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
You talked a lot about people
finding the urban lifestyle
more attractive and moving
from suburbs to cities.
I'm curious, in your research,
was there any data that
suggested the opposite move,
from the suburbs to a more
rural environment, or to
stand-alone towns that
wouldn't be considered a suburb,
with just how easy it
is to be connected.
LEIGH GALLAGHER: That's a
really good question.
Most of the research seems to
suggest that people are
looking for more urban
and more connection.
You can totally get that
in the right kind
of small town, though.
I mean, the town I grew up in
that I write a lot about is
very much a kind of Grover's
Corners-esque type of place.
And what people want is
connection and community.
And that was totally lost in
the way we kind of ended up
maxing out our suburbs.
But it does exist in small
towns, completely.
Another-- some people suggested
to me that the
future is in dual home
ownership, where you have--
you see a lot of that in New
York, where you have your
urban dwelling and then
you have your
place in the country.
And I think it's a rarefied
slice of the population that
can live that way.
But this person was sort of
saying, no, you can do it--
people at income levels that
you'd be surprised at, this is
going to be kind of the
way of the future.
So I don't know.
I think with rural--
I think the appeal
of the small town
definitely plays a role.
One economist I talked
to talked about--
He had a word for it.
Cities with 300,000 or less, he
thinks that's going to be
the future.
So that's hardly small town.
That's hardly rural.
But smaller cities.
So that's one other aspect.
JESSI HEMPEL: Let's jump
right over here.
AUDIENCE: So I grew
up in Wisconsin.
And pretty much all of Wisconsin
is either a suburb
or a rural area.
And one of the ways I'd always
thought about suburbs--
I grew up in very much a
cookie cutter suburb--
is sort of on the border
between the
urban and the rural.
Sort of places that
exist that--
sort of geographic in nature,
just places adjacent to both
types of communities.
And I hadn't really thought
about it from the lifestyle
perspective, or the choices, et
cetera, I'm sure my parents
had thought about very deeply.
I guess if you extrapolate
outwards the trends that
you're seeing, what happens to
that place in between the
cities and the rural areas.
What do you call those and what
function do they serve?
And I guess I'd just be
interested to hear you sort of
look forward.
LEIGH GALLAGHER: Yeah.
Well, I mean what you're
describing--
I mean, the suburbs, that's
how they were designed.
It was like, here's cities.
Here's the country.
We're going to throw them
together and come up with the
perfect mixture.
Like the perfect solution.
It's going to be--
bake them together and we'll
have the best of both worlds.
But I think you're talking
about more of the remote
suburbs that are closer to the
rural farmland and stuff,
where farmers made a lot of
money by selling their land to
developers.
And actually, now a lot of those
farmers are making a lot
of money on the other end by
buying them back for nothing.
They are.
JESSI HEMPEL: Oh, the irony.
LEIGH GALLAGHER: Yeah, it is.
It's great.
But there's a big question.
What happens to all
these houses?
If people are going to migrate
inward, what happens to them?
There's the theory of economics
that if a price
falls low enough, it'll be
of value to someone.
So maybe landlords will
come in and try to
rent out those houses.
Maybe communities--
they'll become immigrant
communities of a certain type.
Maybe big extended families
will take
over these big houses.
Maybe they'll turn into artist
lofts or something.
So there's all sorts of uses
that have been proposed for
these houses that we have
that are built far way.
And that arguably there won't be
a market for in the future,
because we're also not having
as many children, which is
another factor.
But that's anybody's guess.
I mean, a lot of enterprising
investors are buying up
hundreds of single-family
homes with the intent of
renting them out.
And it remains to be seen
if that's going to be a
sustainable solution.
But very good question.
JESSI HEMPEL: Let's
jump over here.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to
ask you specifically
about Silicon Valley.
And I wanted to know if that
fits into your general thesis
or if it's sort of an exception
because of all of
the wealth creation and
jobs that are there.
LEIGH GALLAGHER: That's a
really good question.
It fits in.
I would say Palo Alto is a good
example of the old burb.
It's got this quaint town.
It's got a real center.
It's a place that a lot
of people want to be.
The neighborhood is
built at scale.
The streets are narrow.
There's sidewalks.
The houses are built a little
close together.
So it all has all the
bones there that
make up a good suburb.
There was sprawl outside
of San Francisco.
I mean, you saw it especially
in the East Bay, but
all over the place.
So a lot of those
things happen.
But San Francisco came up in
my research a little bit.
A large part, I talk about
what companies are doing.
And a lot of companies are
moving back to opening in big
cities or shuttering their big
suburban office parks and
opening in cities.
So in San Francisco, you see
some of the hottest startups
in the past couple years have
opened in the city instead of
in the valley.
I mean, Google is obviously
the exception to that.
But look at where we
are right now.
I mean, 20 years ago, Google
would have probably decided to
locate in Mount Kisco.
I mean, it's just-- that's a
really good example of how
things have changed.
This building that we're in
right now, and the price that
was paid for it and
how in demanded it
is, tells you a lot.
But Silicon Valley
is interesting.
It does fit the trend
in certain ways.
JESSI HEMPEL: Let's jump
right over here.
AUDIENCE: You spoke a little bit
about race as it pertains
to home ownership.
But I wonder a bit if--
if you know a bit about
statistics about religious
preference or maybe immigrant
communities that might find a
more isolated neighborhood
to be preferable.
LEIGH GALLAGHER: One of
the things I found--
I mean, people like to live
around people like them.
So families like to live
around other families.
People of different religious
persuasions or beliefs or
whatever like to be around
people that are like them.
Young single people like
to be around other
young single people.
So that happens in
the suburbs.
That happens in the cities.
I mean, you look
at Williamsburg
and the Hasidic community.
So I think that's always
going to be the case.
But those people might be moving
to different places.
AUDIENCE: But I guess
my point is that--
and I'm making an assumption
here, which is that religious
groups and immigrant populations
tend to have
larger families.
I don't know if those
are true, but I
believe they're true.
LEIGH GALLAGHER: That's true.
That's true statistically.
And we need that.
We need those people.
The birth rate in this country
is falling like a stone.
And that's a whole
other reason--
I have a whole chapter
on demographics.
We're not having children
anymore.
I mean, it's not that dramatic,
but it almost is.
I talk about-- this is not
related to your question, but
my father grew up on a block in
an inner spring suburb in
Philadelphia where there were
41 children on his block.
And this was in the '50s.
And I hired a private
investigator to count how many
children there are in
that block now.
And it's a little
bit informal.
JESSI HEMPEL: Creepy.
LEIGH GALLAGHER: What?
LEIGH GALLAGHER: I know.
But there's 15 or fewer.
And that's playing out all
over this country.
So we need the immigrant
population to sustain our
longevity as a country.
JESSI HEMPEL: OK,
right over here.
AUDIENCE: As you mentioned in
that story you told earlier,
you had a couple that moved
out to the suburbs for the
space and the schools,
obviously.
What are the trends with
urban schools?
Are they getting better?
LEIGH GALLAGHER: That's the
huge issue, because
it's like, oh, great.
Everyone wants to
live in a city.
Well, the schools have to be
good for that to happen--
to draw the young families.
And they're--
I talked to a developer here who
owns a company based in--
it's Jonathan Rose Company.
He's a big developer.
And he said that all his young
people-- all his employees
live in the city.
They're all making it work.
They're all finding schools,
whether its magnet schools or
public schools that are good
or whatever, because not
everybody can afford
private schools.
JESSI HEMPEL: Is that in
New York specifically?
LEIGH GALLAGHER: That's
in New York.
He's in New York.
But I talked to someone else in
Philadelphia who's bringing
their kids back and looking
at a sort of
magnet school situation.
That's a big question mark.
And I think the schools
need to get better.
I think they are
getting better.
But on the other hand, I think
schools in the suburbs are
going to face continuing
challenges going forward.
You're seeing a lot of them--
as suburbs depopulate and as
suburbs age because of this
declining birth rate, a lot of
schools are having to merge or
close and they're seeing their
taxpayer-funded resources decline.
And that trend is going
to accelerate.
So I think it might even
out a little bit
more than people think.
JESSI HEMPEL: Right over here.
AUDIENCE: So the suburbs grew
out of World War II.
And part of that growth,
too, was television and
advertising.
And we see television viewership
on decline.
I think it's near
all-time lows.
Can you say anything about
the American consumer?
And if the end of the suburbs
is coming, will that also
portend the end of the
American economy?
Where are the lawn tractors
going to go to?
All the stuff we get
out of Home Depot.
LEIGH GALLAGHER: Yeah,
that's a good point.
Good point.
I mean, I think it's changing.
So right, in the '50s, suburbia
was baked into every
single consumer marketing
image you could imagine,
whether it's TV commercial
or an add on a
billboard or whatever.
So now we're just seeing those
images in different places.
And those images might
be changing.
So maybe the American dream is
not a lawnmower and a yard.
But it's a great Wi-Fi
connection and a really cool
place for entertaining
your friends.
And there's different kind--
it's true.
I mean, that's what the
millennials want.
I mean, that's a lot of
you in the room here.
But people are poking and
prodding and studying the
millennials to see how they want
to live and where they
want to live.
And how they want to live their
lives, because that is
going to answer the question you
just asked of what is the
consuming economy going
to look like.
And the studies show that they
don't want a car, which is a
whole other story.
The number of kids getting their
driver's licenses is
dropping, which is really weird
to anybody who grew up
in the '70s or earlier.
And they want other things.
So they want devices.
They want their gadgets.
They want their smartphones.
They want their Google
everything.
So that's the difference.
JESSI HEMPEL: Leigh,
another--you and I were
talking about this
on the way over.
Another way to sort of frame
that idea and to really tie
what you were talking about to
your thesis is to think about
what was going on in
the 20th century.
I mean, the 20th century
was about mass, right?
It was about mass production.
It was broadcast media.
It was producing things
at scale.
And the internet came along and
really disrupted that at
the end of the 20th century.
And so the 21st century is about
technology in search of
personalization.
So all of our models are
breaking down on every level.
LEIGH GALLAGHER: Yep.
I think that's a great
way to put it.
That's exactly right.
I mean, everything was broadcast
instead of cable and
everything.
And so now people want that
same kind of customization
from their communities.
Why should you have to just
choose from A or B, cul-de-sac
or skyscraper?
For a long time, that
was kind of our
choices in this country.
I'm not really exaggerating
that much.
And so now people want lots
of different options.
And that's why this is really
a positive story, because
people are going to be able to
pick and choose and have a lot
more options at their disposal
when it comes to where they
want to live, how they want to
live, how they want to spend
their time, which is a huge
part of where you live.
And I think that totally
replicates the kind of
changing narrative of what's
happening in our country.
That is a great way
to put it, Jesse.
JESSI HEMPEL: So we have time
for one more question.
AUDIENCE: So I was curious
when you were doing your
research if you got into at all
what I would characterize
as sort of the dysfunctionality
or
schizophrenia of a lot of these
suburban towns and their
governments.
Like in the town I live in, and
it's very common the area
I live in, there are these
endless fights about the
school budget and about funding
different things.
And about, should we have green
space or should we let
that space be developed, because
then that would lead
to more ratables?
Or you can be in one town and
your taxes can be 30% lower
than the town next to you
because the town next to you
has some big company like IBM in
it or something like that.
And I was wondering if you got
into at all sort of their
whole suburban model of local
government and whether it's
going to work going forward.
LEIGH GALLAGHER: You know,
that's a really good question.
I didn't spend too much
time on that.
I mean, I did want to
go and sit in on
one of those meetings.
I think that would have been
something really fun to do.
But I didn't get
the chance to.
You know, that may change.
I mean, I think we're
going to have--
the taxpayer base is going to
increasingly shift in the
suburbs to older people.
And it's going to become a
bigger, kind of more diverse
mix as the suburbs become kind
of jumbled up and as people
see their incomes decline.
I think those fights are going
to get worse because you're
not going to have one faction
that only wants the
schools to be good.
You're going to have
multiple factions.
So I don't see that changing.
I think I see it
getting worse.
JESSI HEMPEL: Do you think that
people are less involved
in their town or city government
when they live in
cities as opposed to suburbs?
Do they feel less ownership
over it?
LEIGH GALLAGHER: Well, cities
work in kind of micro
communities anyway.
So that's a really-- that's
a good question.
I mean, Robert Putnam wrote
great book, "Bowling Alone,"
in the '80s or so.
And a lot of people suggest
that sprawl actually makes
people less connected and feel
less sense of community, even
though that's what
the suburbs were
designed to kind of foster.
So I think you see a lot of
community activism in cities.
JESSI HEMPEL: So last
question, Leigh.
You've been all over the United
States and the world in
reporting this book.
Do you have a suggestion for
those of us who are being
priced out of Brooklyn?
Des Moines or Birmingham?
LEIGH GALLAGHER: Well, I always
say in New York we're
really lucky because we have
a lot of those older
suburbs around us.
So if you do want to move to
the suburbs here, you have
some great choices.
But I'm still looking for that
perfect utopia where you kind
of cut and paste Brooklyn and
you put it somewhere else
that's cheaper and
more affordable.
JESSI HEMPEL: Well, thank you
to Google for having us in.
And thanks to Leigh.
LEIGH GALLAGHER:
Thanks so much.
JESSI HEMPEL: And the big
question I'm sure you're all
wondering--
I can't believe I almost got off
the stage without telling
you this, but there are
many ways to get
Leigh's book, in fact.
You could buy it, you could
download it on Google Play, or
you could ask for it for
Christmas from a loved one who
could get it for everyone.
LEIGH GALLAGHER: Great
idea, Jessi.
JESSI HEMPEL: What
do you think?
LEIGH GALLAGHER:
That is great.
And I think there are a limited
number back there, but
they might--
I don't know if they're still
up there or not, but
there are some here.
So feel free to take
one or buy one.
JESSI HEMPEL: Thank you.
LEIGH GALLAGHER: Thanks
again, everybody.
Thanks for great questions.